Joe Biden not the best and the brightest
Kamala Harris not the best and the
brightest but speaking of not the best
and the brightest we had a little debate
we had a debate this morning do we play
a video of John fetterman it is such
low-hanging fruit this thing is so
ridiculous it is so patently absurd that
this man is a senator that do we show
you this now he got out of he was in a
home he was in like Shady Pines or
something he was a little depressed a
little depressed he was in a home hasn't
really done much work finally they get
him out there he is the senator from
Pennsylvania as you know they're at a
senate hearing and here unedited
unedited for you is about 90 seconds to
John fetterman may God have mercy on
your soul
is is it staggering is it a staggering
responsive responsibility that the the
head of a bank could literally could
literally crash our economy
it's astonishing that's like if you have
I mean like and and they also realize is
that that that now they have it's in the
guaranteed a guaranteed way to be saved
by again by no matter no matter if I
have my how you know so it's it's you
know isn't it appropriate that the those
kinds of this kind of control should be
more stricter
to prevent this kind of thing from going
or should we just go on and start
bailing and sailing whoever Bank
regardless of how however there's their
conduct is
you know I'll give you an example uh the
Republicans want to give a work
requirement for snap you know for a a a
a hungry family has to to have these
this kind of penalties are these some
kinds of word working uh required
shouldn't you have a working requirement
after we sell your bank with billions of
your bank
because they seem to be more preoccupied
uh when then snap and their requirements
for works for Hungry people but not
about protecting the tax the tax papers
you know that will fail no matter
whatever does about a bank to crash it
all right honestly I don't know whether
to laugh or cry I really don't we all
kind of had the same reaction and we've
already watched it this morning it's
like first off this where he stops
several times the implication is Now
respond right so I wish they had had the
video on the person he's talking to as
well because how could you ever respond
to any of that right it's it's circular
it's confused it's muddled like you sort
of have a sense of what he's saying that
we shouldn't be bailing out Banks
because he wants money to go to other
programs snap programs but it's just
like do you think honestly does anyone
in this country honestly believe this
man should be a senator Dr Oz could have
been the senator and you might not like
Dr Oz for whatever reason you may not
think he was great maybe he didn't spend
enough time in Pennsylvania whatever it
is but Dr Oz would be up there speaking
in full sentences
[Music]
thank you